-Welcome back. Welcome back.
-Thank you for having me back.
-Thanks for being here.
We have so much to talk about.
-We do?
-Yes.
This is your first time back
since hosting
"Saturday Night Live."
-Yes.
-I mean, this is --
You were fantastic.
You were --
-Thank you!
-It was a great episode.
You were fantastic.
Were you nervous going in?
-You know, I was nervous
for a second
because I have to be honest,
I had never seen "SNL" before.
I had gone to one taping
of Eddie Murphy,
but I had never --
And I'd gone backstage --
[ Laughter ]
-You've never seen
"Saturday Night Live"?
-No.
-Like serious, serious?
-I'm dead serious.
And, so --
-Did you think --
-I know what it --
I knew what it was.
I knew it was so iconic,
but I had never --
I gotta be honest.
I had no idea you were on.
[ Laughter, sad tuba plays ]
-Wow! I didn't know that.
I mean, it's not
like you said that you did,
but you really --
-I even -- Like a month after,
I had this --
I was at dinner,
and Will Ferrell
was sitting right next to me.
And the show had just aired,
when I was on.
And he, you know,
mentioned he had seen it.
And I literally had to text Pete
and be like, "Wait.
Was Will Ferrell on 'SNL'?"
And I was so embarrassed.
Like, I
literally -- I've been schooled.
I know everyone
that's been on now.
I know everything.
-Oh, my gosh.
-So I've been schooled.
But I really didn't know.
-I'm hearing kids.
-Guys, can you stop?
This is, like, your first time
at work with me.
Can you please?
-Your kids are right there.
Well, that is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My two boys are here,
and then my friend Tracy's
daughter, Remi, is here with us.
-Hi, Remi. Hi, boys. Welcome.
-My two boys are here, and I
hear them making so much noise.
Guys, this is your first time
at work with me.
Don't mess this up. Come on.
-I mean, but your daughter,
North, just turned 9.
-She just turned 9.
-How did you celebrate
North's --
-So, she's really into
special-effects makeup.
She does, like,
really good, like,
wounds and scars and really --
-What?
-She's really good at it.
So, she was taking classes.
So, she wanted to have
a spooky wilderness-themed
birthday party,
so I took them out camping
in the wilderness.
Guys, seriously. You got to go.
-You don't have --
They can go back
if you don't feel like
being out here.
It's fine.
-Okay, Psalmy left.
He was being loud. Okay.
-He was being loud.
Wait, wait.
So, tell me about this.
So, wait.
How did she get into knowing
about all that makeup and --
-She just -- I have no idea.
That's a really good question.
I should be concerned.
I have no idea
how she got into it,
but I got her a teacher
to show her
and get all of the supplies.
So, she wanted to
teach her girlfriends.
And we took about eight kids,
eight girls,
and we went camping
in the wilderness.
And she wanted it
to be really spooky
and she wanted,
like, these mannequin heads.
And she taught everyone.
There was a whole class
that she taught her friends
how to do special-effects,
wounds, and scars and --
-I'm happy that you said that.
I thought that there was
just gonna be a bunch of
mannequin heads
scattered around the woods.
I was like,
"That's really too scary."
Oh, my gosh.
-No, no.
-I love that.
You recently posted
a video of North singing
"We Don't Talk About Bruno."
-Oh, yeah.
-And she can really sing.
-Yeah, she raps. She sings.
She loves it. Yeah.
-It's very cute.
-She knows "We Don't Talk About
Bruno" in eight languages.
She knows how to sing it
in eight languages.
So, I was at The Met
and I saw Lin and I go,
"I love you and I hate you.
I cannot hear this song
one more time in my household."
-Oh, it's all over the place.
-Yeah. Eight languages.
Like, Japanese, Portuguese --
-It's so cute.
I want to show everyone a video.
Check this out.
-♪ It was my wedding day ♪
-♪ It was our wedding day ♪
-♪ We were ready, and there
wasn't a cloud in the sky ♪
-♪ No clouds allowed
in the sky ♪
-♪ Bruno walks in with
a mischievous grin ♪
-Thunder!
-♪ You telling this story
or am I? ♪
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That got a smile on his face.
So, the girl
in the video is her sister.
-That's her sister, yeah.
You have a performer
on your hands.
I can already tell.
-My two girls are.
-My littlest daughter,
Chi-Chi --
she just had a performance,
and the teacher told us,
when she went back after
the performance, she goes,
"Can I go out there again
and do it again?
I loved everyone
clapping for me."
-I want to tell you this
before I forget, but you --
My wife cried when
you passed the bar, by the way.
She was so happy for you.
-So did I.
-She was so so happy for you.
And she was like, "Yes!"
-That's so nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She got emotional.
Like, "Dude, I got so emotional
watching 'The Kardashians.'"
I was like --
We love the whole family.
You have a very talented family.
Actually, we have a video of you
and your sisters singing
when you were around
North's age,
lip-synching to Tiffany's
"I Think We're Alone Now."
Here's your debut.
Take a look at this.
-♪ I think we're alone now ♪
♪ There doesn't seem to be
anyone around ♪
♪ I think we're alone now ♪
♪ The beating of our hearts
is the only sound ♪
-I think -- It's so funny.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kim, you were like, "I think
we're --" Having no fun.
-I know.
It's like no personality there.
-Having no fun at all.
-My mom and
her friends would throw
these parties at a place
called "Closet Stars."
And they would do these videos.
I don't know if they'd be,
like, drinking wine
and just putting us in a room
to, like, keep us busy.
But the outfits? Yeah.
-That's half -- See?
Well, it all begins somewhere.
It all starts somewhere.
I want to talk about your
new skin-care line, SKKN.
Look at how gorgeous this is.
-Don't drop it.
-I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-I mean, I want it
just for the packaging.
This is gorgeous.
-It is unisex.
And I do love --
I wanted it, like,
to be very masculine
at the same time.
Just I love how it looks
on my counter.
And I don't have
a lot out on my counter.
Everything is really minimal.
But I wanted my packaging
and my skin-care to be able to
sit on my counter
and just look beautiful.
-It looks gorgeous.
It's SKKN. S-K-K-N -- SKKN.
-Yeah, with a nod, like, Kim K.
Had it in there a little bit.
SKKN by Kim.
-Yeah.
So it's skknbykim.com
These are nine products here.
This is your --
Is this your routine every day?
This is your daily face routine?
-This is my daily face routine.
So, there's nine products,
but you'll use
eight in the morning
and then you'll substitute
one of them for a night serum.
So it'll be -- It's -- You use,
really, eight at one time.
-Does this feel like a lot?
-No.
No, because here's the thing.
People want an easy, quick fix.
And this just -- I --
Even people were telling me to
launch with like three products,
and that's just not what I use
for my skin-care routine.
So, it does take a lot of work,
and I wanted to --
I formulated this all with
the most amazing
chemists and facialists,
and I've learned so much.
-Everyone here
in our makeup department
is freaking out.
They're like, "This is --"
Like, everyone's already heard
about it and read about it.
Like, this is the best.
You've done it.
-It's -- Thank you.
I mean, I worked so hard on it,
and it's --
You know, the science
and everything will back up
all of the ingredients
in the formulas and --
-Yeah. Does Pete give you
any input on the skin-care?
I think he has
a good skin-care routine.
-Actually, that's,
like, one of the reasons why.
That's, like,
one of our major bonding things.
-Is skin-care?
-We go to
dermatologists together.
We inject our pimples
together at the same time.
-Wow!
-Yeah, the dermatologist
is like, "Is this contagious?
You guys always have pimples
at the same time."
-That's how in tune
you guys are.
-Like, I knew it was special
when I fell asleep
and I kept on talking about
it all night, like, "Oh, my God.
I have this pimple.
Don't let me fall asleep.
I have to put pimple medicine on
it before I go to sleep."
I fell sleep, forgot,
woke up in the morning with
dried pimple medicine
on my face.
-He put it on --
-He put it on in my sleep.
-The gentleman. Oh, my God.
Pete.
-Such a gentleman.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I saw a video.
You were demoing
the products for SKKN.
And at the end,
you did a face massage.
Is that --
-You want me to try it on you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, of course.
-Come on. Please? Can I?
-Of course.
-Can I go around?
-Yeah, of course. You want to?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Alright, what do we --
-Let me pick an oil.
Oh, an oil. Okay.
-This is an oil.
What do I -- what do I do?
♪♪
Do I lay back?
No, I just sit here.
What do I --
I don't know what to do.
-Just --
-Okay, just chill.
-Yeah. Oh, sorry.
-I'm ready. No problem.
I guess I got to --
Got a hand massage, as well.
-Okay, so, it's all about, like,
the jowls and the neck for me.
So, like, the facialist --
she, like, smacks me like this.
-Yep, yep, yep. I'm feeling it.
It's already working.
-To get really in there.
You've got to,
like, wake your skin up.
-Saint, Saint,
am I doing a good job?
-Saint, help me, please.
-Saint.
-Saint, get over here
and help me, please.
Am I doing it okay?
-There you go.
-Alright, wait. Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel fantastic.
-Guys, does he
look so much better?
-Yes, I feel it! I feel alive!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kim Kardashian, everybody.
Her new skin-care line, SKKN,
is available now
at skknbykim.com.